SIERRA: It’s March, and it’s been nearly
a year since COVID-19 was declared a pandemic.
There’s no two ways about it, it’s a bitter
anniversary, but it’s also a time to think
about how far we’ve come.
There was so much confusion at the start about
how to protect ourselves.
Now, a year later, we’ve learned a lot about
how to stay safe, and we’ve developed highly
effective vaccines in record time.
We’re starting to see the light at the end
of the tunnel.
But there is at least one more hurdle that
threatens to undo our progress.
All around the world, wealthy countries are
hoarding vaccines, leaving huge swaths of
the global population without access.
Global health officials say that this could
be a lethal mistake for rich and poor countries
alike.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, why a global pandemic needs a global
response.
NBC News: It’s been almost a year ago when
the country began shutting down from Covid
and for the first time, there seems to be
a real reason to have cautious optimism.
PBS NewsHour: Who gets vaccines and when are
not only serious questions in the U.S but
also around the globe.
DW: In the global fight against Covid-19,
its mutations have been proving to be the
next great challenge.
SIERRA: So we have a lot of really important
stuff to talk about.
But I feel like one of those important things
is that both you and I are South Brooklyn
children.
And I feel like it was really important to
just get that out of the way.
FAUCI: Where were you?
Where were you in South Brooklyn?
SIERRA: I'm from Manhattan Beach.
FAUCI: You are?
SIERRA: Yeah.
FAUCI: I'm from Bensonhurst.
SIERRA: I know.
Yeah.
Well, I you need no introduction, but I'll
just start the way we always start, which
is what is your name?
And what do you do?
FAUCI: My name is Dr. Anthony Fauci.
And I'm the director of the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases at the
National Institutes of Health.
SIERRA: Alright.
So, let’s say that the majority of Americans
were vaccinated tomorrow.
Would we be fully in the clear?
FAUCI: So if we got let's say 70 to 85 percent
of the people in the country vaccinated, then
we would be very much better off than we are
now.
But there's a real catch to your question.
Because even if we got the overwhelming majority
of the population vaccinated, there is a big
wide world out there.
And that's the global pandemic.
So if the rest of the world did not get COVID-19,
or SARS-CoV-2, under control, there would
always be a looming threat over us that the
virus would be mutating, would be changing,
and we would get new variants that even if
we felt ourselves protected in this country,
sooner or later, a variant or a mutation could
come here, and essentially circumvent the
protection of the vaccine.
So I think when you think in terms of a pandemic,
you have to remember it is global.
And it requires a global response, not just
a single country response.
HAASS: In the old days, when we used to get
on airplanes, you remember that?
When we could all travel?
One of the first things you get is this disembodied
voice that would say, in the event of a loss
of cabin pressure, oxygen masks will come
down from the overhead.
SIERRA: This is Richard Haass, president of
the Council on Foreign Relations, former director
of policy planning for the State Department,
adviser to two Presidents, and...my boss.
HAASS: And you are instructed by this voice
to put it on yourself.
And then only after you yourself are safe
and taken care of, then you turn to your children,
your neighbors and others.
And that's our instinct here.
We've got to jettison that instinct.
Unless the rest of the world gets vaccinated,
it doesn't just threaten their lives, that
threatens ours too.
Because if we don't take care of others, variants
will continue to break out.
And when variants break out over there, they
will figure out a way to come here.
So then we end up in a race that never quite
ends, and that we never quite win.
SIERRA: To stay ahead of the curve we have
to understand variants.
And in order to understand variants, we have
to understand mutations.
And in order to understand mutations, we went
to the country’s medical explainer-in-chief.
SIERRA: So what is a mutation?
Where do they tend to come from?
Why do we need to worry about them?
FAUCI: When viruses replicate, which they
do very, very rapidly, particularly when you
have literally 100 million people infected,
which is what we have right now in the world
with, you know, over 2.4 million deaths.
When you have that amount of replication,
as the virus replicates, it makes mistakes
in reproducing itself.
That's called a mutation.
SIERRA: Mutations are alterations to a sequence.
A lot of people explain this by comparing
it to a misspelled word.
So, let’s say you’re sending a text.
You’re moving fast, and you spell something
wrong.
Probably not a big deal.
Your friend understands what you mean.
But what if that misspelled word actually
changes the meaning of your sentence?
Now your friend is upset, and you have to
deal with the fallout.
A virus mutation is similar.
As viruses replicate quickly, mistakes are
made.
Most of these mistakes won’t matter much,
but sometimes the change allows a virus to
become something very different.
FAUCI: When you get a constellation of mutations,
then you can get what's called a variant,
namely, a strain of virus that varies considerably
from what the original virus was.
That's very important.
Because if you make a vaccine against one
of the iterations of the virus, and it changes,
mutates, and becomes a variant, you may either
weaken or even lose the protection of the
vaccine.
SIERRA: Mutations that can’t be stopped
with current vaccines are worrisome, but they
aren’t the only concern.
Epidemiologists are also on the lookout for
strains that are more deadly, strains that
are more contagious, and strains that are
not detectable with our current tests.
No matter where they arise, variants can travel
and become a problem for the entire world.
And this isn’t hypothetical; new variants
that developed in California and New York
are spreading as we speak, as are several
that emerged abroad.
CBC News: The new coronavirus variant identified
in the UK has now made it into Canada.
ABC News: News this evening of the dangerous
South African variant has now been detected
in a patient here in the New York City in
a hospital.
KHOU 11 News: We begin with the Brazil variant
of the coronavirus detected in Minnesota.
Scientists say this variant spreads more quickly.
FAUCI: Any place where you have a lot of viral
replication with a lot of infection is by
definition a hotspot for the evolution of
mutations.
It's a very firm axiom of virology, that if
you're not replicating, you can't mutate.
So the best way to prevent a virus from mutating
is to dampen down dramatically its spread
from person to person, because the more it
spreads, the more opportunity it has to mutate.
SIERRA: So...could this set us back to square
one?
FAUCI: Well, it is unlikely that it would
set us back to square one, but it certainly
could interfere with the progress.
Let me give you the scientific explanation
for that.
So right now, there are two major variants
that we are concerned about.
One of them is a variant that evolved from
mutations that occurred in the strain in the
UK.
And it is now dominated in the UK.
It transmits from person to person more efficiently
than the original virus.
And it is even more dangerous, that it could
potentially make you more ill and even lead
to a greater degree of hospitalization.
Right now, that variant is in the United States.
And modelers projected that by the time you
get to the end of March, that it could be
the dominant strain in the United States.
That's sobering news.
The good news is that the vaccines that we
are distributing now in the United States
happen to work very well against [it].
However, there's another troublesome variant
that is dominating in the Republic of South
Africa.
That one is replicating rapidly and causing
a lot of disease in South Africa.
It is also in the United States, but in a
very minor way.
The reason we're more concerned is that the
vaccines that we're using are diminished multiple
folds in their capability of controlling that.
It hasn't eliminated the ability to control
it.
But it considerably diminishes its capability.
So that's the one that we really need to watch
out for.
SIERRA: As the virus replicates scientists
know that it’s only a matter of time until
other variants emerge.
And the possibility is always there that a
new variant could be more deadly, harder to
trace, and perhaps even immune to existing
vaccines.
This is why vaccinating your own country isn’t
the real finish line.
FAUCI: The entire global community needs to
have access to vaccines, if we really are
going to durably control this outbreak, which
brings us to the point of the fact that the
United States and other developed nations,
like the UK, and the EU, and Canada, and Australia,
and Japan, and other countries that have resources,
very well would likely have to put in whatever
it takes to get that part of the world that
doesn't have the resources to develop and
or administer vaccines.
So in other words, it's got to be a global
effort that is involving countries that have
the resources to be able to contribute to
the overall effort.
SIERRA: The process for obtaining vaccines
is complicated.
Most of it has been done through a bidding
process in which wealthy countries competed
with each other to secure as many doses as
possible directly from manufacturers.
This distribution model is based on money,
rather than population or need.
As a result, a small number of nations were
able to secure a majority of doses.
CBS News: A few rich countries, including
U.S. and Canada, have 14 percent of the world
population but control 53 percent of the vaccine
supply.
CNA: 40 percent of the world would not have
widespread access to vaccines until 2023.
That’s more than eighty five countries.
CNN: The basic problem is in how the vaccine
is distributed around the world, not based
on whether there is most need, but the most
money.
SIERRA: There is a global effort to share
and distribute vaccines more equitably.
It’s called COVAX.
It’s a joint effort of three international
organizations, the WHO, GAVI, and CEPI, and
it aims to provide at least two billion vaccine
doses to the world’s most vulnerable populations
by the end of 2021.
It’s already begun sending doses to West
Africa.
But COVAX is only a start.
It’s not clear if it will meet its fundraising
goals, and even then, COVAX will only be equipped
to deliver vaccines to the world’s most
vulnerable people over a period of years.
That’s nowhere near enough to achieve herd
immunity globally and end the pandemic.
Without increased production capacity and
the donation of actual doses, it’s going
to be years before poor countries get vaccinated.
And that means years of gambling on new variants.
In order to better understand how things are
playing out in the developing world we talked
to Tidjane Thiam, a former CEO of Credit Suisse,
who has been appointed by the African Union
to solicit international support for the bloc’s
fight against COVID.
SIERRA: So how might things play out if Africa
doesn't receive international support in this
battle against COVID?
THIAM: Oh, it would be terrible.
Of course.
We've all said many times, but nobody's safe
until everybody's safe.
I mean that is absolutely the case for something
like for Coronavirus, as contagious as COVID
is.
And really Africa had been doing well, going
into this crisis.
The last twenty years have been a period of
huge growth and progress for Africa.
And we feel that there's a real risk that
Africa falls back by ten or fifteen years
in terms of its development, and for a part
of the world where you have 1.2 billion people
that would be catastrophic.
SIERRA: So how did African nations fare in
the race to secure vaccine doses?
THIAM: Well this race is ongoing.
A number of initiatives have been taken.
The most visible is COVAX.
And the objective of COVAX is to cover about
20 percent of the population.
And you know that the key number to achieve
herd immunity is about 60 percent.
So we still have a big gap there.
You know, Africa has honestly reacted reasonably
well, the heads of states are very involved.
The African Union has played a key role.
But one thing, the health systems are very
weak.
The second wave, which we are in right now
has been much worse than the first one.
And you are starting to see the health systems
cracking at the seams.
So for the same level of contagion, you are
likely to see a much higher level of mortality
in Africa, which would be really tragic.
And we don't want to renew the experience
we had with HIV AIDS, where for ten years
we were not able to provide treatment to Africa,
and people died by the hundreds of thousands
when treatments were available.
SIERRA: So are there other important ways
that countries like the US can support the
battle against COVID in Africa beyond providing
the doses themselves?
THIAM: I think the first issue is resources,
money.
We have worked hard to have a kind of debt
deal with the G20 to create some fiscal space
for the African government so they can spend
their scarce resources on procuring for vaccines
and paying back with it.
So this is an ongoing process.
And there are negotiations underway, country
by country, including for the first time China
as a creditor and also the private sector.
So if we get that done, then there will be
enough resources to vaccinate Africans to
a level that provides herd immunity, or 60
percent.
So what we want from the U.S. is support from
that initiative and mobilization to ensure
that we get a physical supply of vaccines.Plus
the delivery, which is also hampered by the
weakness of health system, plus the issues
of storage.
So we need help in buying the vaccines, but
we also need help in ensuring that there's
a delivery system to keep the doses effective
so that people are actually protected.
SIERRA: So you have a lot of experience in
finance.
What do you see playing out economically if
the world does not move to address rampant
COVID transmission in Africa and elsewhere?
THIAM: I mean, Africa today is very well integrated
into the world economy and plays a big role
today for GDP of Africa is $2.5 trillion.
It's as big as India's.
So it's a very large player in international
affairs, and any significant deterioration
in Africa will then reverberate across the
world.
And you don't want a situation where we keep
fighting fires, and this virus travels around
impacting region after region, because also
in the end, this will translate into political
instability, conflict and situation that will
impact everybody around the planet.
SIERRA: Do you have any security concerns
about the countries that are fighting COVID
without vaccine access and without economic
support?
HAASS: The short answer is yes.
What worries me about COVID is that in countries
that can't get the vaccine, this becomes a
form or source, rather, of state weakening.
This becomes one of those things that will
weaken the ability of the state to perform
the functions we expect states to do, provide
public services, among which is security.
So there's a recession going on in much of
the world, this will prolong and deepen a
recession, it will infect security personnel,
it will make it harder for people to go to
their jobs to stay in their jobs to be in
schools.
This is classic of a weak state.
And weak states, by definition, become territories
where bad things happen, where terrorism,
drug cartels, pirates and others set up shop.
SIERRA: How are we going to find the political
will?
Because, even me, right?
I'm counting the days until my friends, my
family, especially my parents can get the
vaccine.
I want the vaccine.
I mean, protecting your own is a strong impulse.
How do we convince people to support the delivery
of vaccines to strangers in other countries?
HAASS: Look, it’s a question I ask myself,
it's totally legit.
And I expect it's the reason that thus far,
the Biden administration, which wants to be
helpful, has limited its help to economic
help.
It has not been willing to make any commitment
as the French president has urged that maybe
even a small percentage of vaccine produced
here to be sent overseas.
SIERRA: The Biden administration has pledged
$2 billion, with another $2 billion to come,
to COVAX.
But it has not yet committed to the more politically
sensitive idea of sending American vaccine
doses abroad.
HAASS: It's a hard sell.
It's a counterintuitive case.
But let me suggest at least two arguments.
That one is the one we've been talking about.
It's the argument of enlightened self- interest.
Don't think of this as a form of just helping
others, not that there's anything wrong with
that.
But think of this as a way of helping ourselves.
The other thing we could do is ramp up supply
over estimates and say we're going to produce,
for argument's sake, enough for two million
doses a day here in the United States, which
is a fantastic level.
If however, we're able to get above that,
we will make those available elsewhere.
Because if we can give doses at the rate of
two million a day, you can do the math, that's
sixty million a month.
That gets us to where we need to be when we
want to get there.
So I think if the President could explain
that, people wouldn't think that we're taking
it out of our own pockets or literally out
of our own arms and putting it in the arms
of others.
SIERRA: If things continue on their current
trajectory, and the U.S. continues to meet
its ambitious goals for vaccinating its own
population, we need to start to think about
the point at which sending vaccines abroad
becomes a better way of protecting ourselves
than simply using them at home.
FAUCI: You can do both.
By the time we get to July, we will have the
contractual arrangements fulfilled by at least
two of the companies to get a total of 600
million doses, for 300 million people.
SIERRA: In fact, the outlook has gotten even
better since we spoke with Dr. Fauci.
The Biden administration now says the U.S.
will have enough doses to cover its entire
population by May.
FAUCI: We should not have to stop there, nor
should other developed nations, nor should
other companies say we're done, we've made
enough vaccines.
We're knee deep and solving our own problem
right now.
But that does not mean that we should not
join the rest of the world, and maybe lead
the rest of the world in addressing the globality
of this pandemic, as opposed to focusing only
on our individual countries.
It means that you have to dramatically increase
the global capacity to make vaccines.
Because we have considerable vaccine-making
capability, but not enough for the whole world.
And so what we need to do is we need to build
the capacity in the form of factories and
plants that can make vaccine in the billions
and billions of doses, for the billions and
billions of people who live on this planet.
So that would require putting up physical
facilities, getting them fitted to make vaccines,
making them in large quantities.
And that is based upon the investment in resources
to do just that.
So what we're going to need is a global commitment,
including by “we” the United States.
SIERRA: You've written recently about the
United States’s diminished global reputation.
I mean, do you think this is an opportunity
to start earning that back?
HAASS: Well, absolutely.
This is a real chance to show that the United
States is back on the playing field, that
this is a country of capacity.
But it’s also a country of care.
It's a way of not leaving the playing field
simply to others, it gets us back in the game.
Look it's one of those chances to do good
and do well.
You know, you don't often get twofers like
this in foreign policy.
But this is a twofer.
We can help others, we can enhance our prestige
overseas, it’s a threefer, and we can make
ourselves safer at the same time.
And the challenge will have less to do with
doing it.
I actually think doing it in this case is
not all that hard.
It's explaining it.
And it's not having it be a political liability.
But that then is a communications challenge.
That's an educational challenge.
It's an explaining challenge.
And I think we are up to it.
SIERRA: Won’t we need help?
How do we get places like Japan or Canada
or the EU to do their part?
HAASS: This should not be and cannot be a
U.S. only effort.
But in my experience, you're much more able
to talk the talk, much more persuasively,
if you walk the walk.
So if the United States is doing what it needs
to do at home, but also producing and making
available a percentage of what it is we generate
here in the way of vaccines, it makes it so
much easier for this government to go to other
governments, hey, follow our lead.
SIERRA: Right.
HAASS: Otherwise, it's called hypocrisy, and
hypocrisy doesn't do you any good in foreign
policy any more than it does you good in your
day-to-day life.
But if we're acting consistently, and we're
not asking others to do more than we ourselves
are prepared to do, then I think we've got
a very strong hand.
SIERRA: What is your definition of success?
When it comes to COVID?
What would life look like?
What will it take to get there?
You know, and besides vaccines, what else
is required?
FAUCI: Success for me, as a medical doctor,
a physician, and a scientist, at a public
health service, is the elimination of COVID-19.
Namely, where there are so few cases in the
country where you don't even notice it, there
are so few.
And that you get to by a successful vaccination
program.
And as we've been discussing, you want to
make sure it stays that way, by vaccinating
the entire world and getting the entire world
protected.
SIERRA: Well, this was wonderful, hopefully
someday very soon I'll be able to run into
you at, you know, L&B Spumoni Gardens or somewhere,
and things will be right back, sir.
FAUCI: Yep, I hope so.
Without masks.
SIERRA: As we move through the tunnel and
out towards the light, we have to remember
that there are a lot of people moving along
with us.
More than seven billion people, in fact.
If we’re going to make it to the end, we
have to get there together.
The first lesson of COVID was that what happens
somewhere far away can change every part of
your life at home.
It may turn out to be the last lesson too.
Helping your neighbors, whether a state over,
a country over, or an ocean over, isn’t
just the right thing, it’s the smart thing.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
For a delicious Sicilian slice from my old
South Brooklyn neighborhood visit L&B Spumoni
Gardens.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hey?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And, please please, if you are a fan of the
show, show us some love!
Give us five stars and leave a review on Apple
Podcasts.
It means so much to us, and it really does
help us to get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Our intern for this semester is Zoe Han.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional research and extra help were provided
by Elena Tchainikova and James McBride.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!